I think there's a healthy aspect to this
nostalgia in one sense because it is
bringing the digital age into
perspective a little bit I've noticed
that younger people and talking to
people say under 40 about my book I've
noticed there's this interesting
uprising upwelling of nostalgia for the
analog era you know younger people seem
to be into vinyl records and all these
things that I used to think of as
artifacts but they really seem to be
making a comeback and I think that's
nice because it sort of is bringing
together past and present into a new
kind of a new confluence or a new hole
you know it seemed like we had almost
left behind the past and stepped into
this new space and we were never going
to look back but you know reality isn't
really like that the past always feeds
into the present and the present
continues to learn from the past and I
think that's what's happening now we're
in this kind of adjustment period but I
do think there's also a an inevitable
danger to too much nostalgia and to
feeling that oh gosh it's gotten scary
now and we can't handle this anymore you
know one of the lessons I learned in my
look back in history is the people who
think we're kind of at the end of
civilization we're about to enter a new
Dark Age because of the technology
that's risen up and threatened our
sanity they're always wrong you know
they always turn out to be wrong they're
basically I mean I understand the
anxiety because adjustment can be hard
but in the end when you look back they
were basically fear mongers and they
didn't see they didn't understand the
great capacity of human beings not just
to adjust but to be resourceful and to
figure out the new places that can
technology can take us if we make the
best use of it fortunately most people
are not in that category most people are
I think at bottom when it comes to
newness and technological evolution most
people are optimists you can see it on
the street you know everybody's having
great fun with these devices sometimes
to a fault sometimes going overboard
which is one of my points but i think we
are ultimately on the right path and we
will get to a better place with these
gadgets
you